but you know the studies show that when
you tell people they don't have free
will like when you tell them about these
neuroscience studies and then you test
them after they're more likely that
behaved unethically it's a cheat on an
exam so the illusion of free will is
actually very adaptive we've evolved to
have this very strong sense of control
over our own agency for reason because
it helps us interact with social
environments right if we know that we
have control if we think we have control
over actions and we are responsible for
actions and then we're going to behave
and we star socially appropriate if
you're you know if you think cool it
doesn't matter anyway my brain is
deciding you know I could just like kill
this person and say my brain made me do
it right so the strong illusion of free
will it evolved for it has a purpose
I'm joined by the lovely Heather Berlin
Heather welcome the show hey thanks for
having me pleasure to have you on today
talking about your daughter's stickers
just behind you they look good I think
that they really adds something to the
room yeah it's kind of those cool
tattoos are like the little ones that
are randomly you know dispersed and it's
just it's that cool kind of look it's
not the same thing that happens when you
have a child they just start adding
little flavor of personality in all of
the rooms all over the house pretty much
pretty much yeah they slowly take over
your life and that's symbolic of that so
um so what do you tell us what it is
that you do what do you spend your days
thinking about and working on okay so
I'm a cognitive neuroscientist and
psychologist and I'm I mean
fundamentally the kind of driving force
in my career has been trying to
understand the fundamental question of
how the physical brain creates our
subjective awareness so basically the
neural basis of consciousness but then I
also got really interested in the neural
basis of all of these unconscious
processes that are motivating our
behavior because much of what we do the
decisions we make our behaviors are
being dictated by things that are
happening outside of our awareness and
we're only consciously where our very
small bit of what's actually happening
we often make up these like post hoc
explanations about why we do things
which are not necessarily the real
reasons so you know we have a narrative
that we tell ourselves so I'm interested
in both the kind of how the physical
brain creates our conscious experience
our subjective states as well as the
unconscious processes that are that are
motivating us explaining how we bathe
Wow
so we got a lot that we can delve into
today we've had a lot of discussions
recently about sort of purpose and
meaning in life and and things like that
but I guess an even more base level the
fact that we are able to be conscious
the fact that we're eight beings that
can kind of consider our own existence
sit before all of that right yeah I mean
you know I think it was Carl Sagan who
said like
we are a way for the you know universe
for matter to know itself right because
it's basically matter that's organizes
itself in such a way that it can you
know have subjective states it can try
to understand itself in its place in the
universe it's pretty amazing but it's
very fundamental I mean when we talk
about consciousness
we don't need language for it we don't
need a sense of self it's really just
pure subjective experience so like you
know tasting something sweet or you know
seeing the color editors are smelling a
rose and other animals have it we you
know assume they do because they have
similar than we that we have they act as
if you know they for example if you step
on a cat's paw it'll pull away and maybe
yell but acts as if it's experiencing
pain we'll never know 100% for sure but
then again I don't know that you're
conscious right I mean I assume you are
but so we just define it it basically
consciousness this first-person
subjective experience you know I just
know that I have it and even when we do
experiments I mean the only way to
really tell is the person has to report
like did you see it or not
you know we've consciously aware that
stimuli or not they have to self-report
and we can make some predictions like
with babies you know where they look
might be what they're attending to or
what they're conscious of but again it's
really this first person's rejected
experience that we're trying to
understand so that's our definition of
consciousness that we're working with
today right yeah it's pretty that's
pretty much it and then there's
different levels you know then there's
like then you add in language or
self-awareness and there ways to sort of
elaborate the subjective experience but
fundamentally what we're trying to
explain is just how a physical piece of
matter could produce this sort of
subjectivity these feelings so how low
down the animal kingdom does this go do
we presume that insects are conscious is
there a line somewhere that we hit yeah
so there's been a lot of debate and
discussion about this topic I was who's
a year or two ago is that a meeting
which is all about animal consciousness
you know what what do we know and so
look we can take it down to you know a
fish a fish for example if you give it
like an oxygen
you know something that might cause them
pain or that's you know offensive you'll
see that might go towards this DUI then
they get a sense of it and they'll move
away write something up say causes pain
but then if you give them something like
a type of anesthesia that kind of blocks
their pain receptors then they don't
move away from the the noxious stimuli
so the idea with this is that they were
feeling something right because when you
block their give them kind of anesthesia
then they no longer retract from that
stimuli right so we assume there's some
sort of feeling there and now how far
down the animal kingdom it's hard to say
for this we really need a sort of a
fundamental overarching theory of
consciousness so for example one theory
that is pretty popular is called the
integrated information theory of
consciousness which basically says that
any system that has a high degree of a
degree of integrated differentiated
information will have the property of
consciousness it's like a fundamental
property of the universe like gravity so
the brain happens to be one of those
systems where let me say integrating it
means like if one neuron fires it will
directly affect whether the neuron next
to it fires right there's integration of
information rather than say a pixel in
your phone goes out like it's not going
to affect the one next to it right so
that's not integrated so we talked about
high degree of integrated information
and so the brain happens to be one of
those systems and then basically there's
a mathematical calculation called Phi
which you can calculate the amount of
differentiated integrated information of
a system and that predicts how conscious
it is so if we go along with that your
consciousness we can look at like a B or
you know a fetus and try to make a
measure of how much Phi it has and C but
I'll do this theory basically it's kind
of pants like it means anything like a
light switch has a bit of information
right it's you're either on or off
so in some sense would have a degree a
bit of Phi so it gets very like
philosophical so that's just one theory
you know so again it depends on the
theory you know I think you have to have
some sort of nervous system to have a
consciousness like you know some people
talk about plant consciousness and
things like that and I just don't think
that they have necessarily subjective
States or any kind of
feeling but I mean I could be wrong it
might feel like something to be a plant
that like responds to light and starts
growing towards it you know um I think
the sort of the anecdotal quote that
I've heard from Sam Harris is that
consciousness within any being is if
there is something that it is alike to
be that being if there is something
there is like to be a plant or if there
is something that is like to be a B
because we know with pretty good
certainty that there is nothing that it
is like to be a rock or like there's
nothing really that it is like to be
this table apart from maybe when it was
still alive when it was a tree but yeah
so is that is that kind of touching on
what we're talking about there is that
it's not coming from a difference I mean
that's one way to look at it but you
know some might argue that say the
interactions you know between you know
the molecules within the rock or have
some level of you know Phi I mean
there's different leader levels of this
argument yeah and what does it mean to
be like something I mean how would we
ever know if it is like anything to be
lets say a plant right so we don't know
because it responds to its environment
it might just respond reflexively and we
don't know that there's anything till
it's like to be that so it's a it's an
interesting definition but it's very
hard to then test it - then you know
prove like well is it like something
it's a baby I don't know how do we know
yeah you know how much of your work is
sort of theoretical and how much of it
is experimental well I mean all the
experiments are based on some theory
right so you have a kathiria many of
hypotheses you do the experiments so so
much of it is is trying time chef I mean
I I like to ask these big questions when
it comes to doing research you know it's
much more practical endeavor and
especially working most of my career at
a medical school and Department of
Psychiatry you know a lot of it is so so
as I see some of my research is
interested in that overarching question
but a lot of it is more practical in the
sense of what's the neural basis
of different psychiatric disorders or in
particular symptoms within psychiatric
disorders and how can we come up with
novel treatments for those symptoms
whether it's impulsivity or compulsive
behavior so it's mapping out doing sort
of these correlations between underlying
brain mechanisms and dysfunction and
then trying to kind of fix that either
with drugs or cognitive treatments and
the like so that's more practical
aspects of my research that's so
fascinating that you've got this
subjective experience which is anxiety
or happiness or depression or a thought
pattern or whatever it might be and the
thing that kind of blows my mind is that
the way that we feel something inside of
our heads is is one particular
experience but that actually manifests
as something physically happening within
the brain right it's a particular series
of neurons firing but we don't feel it
like a series of neurons firing we see a
elephant when we think of an elephant or
we imagine a smell when we think of a
smell or we can change our you know us
emotional state when we think of that
that that sort of time at the place
where those two things mean to me seems
so crazy well I think that's also why
there's so much stigma around mental
illness because you know let's say you I
don't know you have like a bacterial
infection like oh there's this vector
I'll take this antibiotic and that will
help it or you break a bone and you know
you take whatever to fix the bone but
when the brain is sort of broken or not
working properly
we just don't see it as like in a
dysfunction of an organ we see it as is
this function of a human being right and
because it's just these subjective
States and people often forget that it's
really it's tied to a physical mechanism
right so if there's a dysfunction in
let's say your way of thinking it's a
problem related to the brain somehow and
we don't always know exactly how but but
you know with enough time and research
we can figure that out and then ultimate
the treatment can be targeted at the
brain itself um you know I think talking
every like cognitive behavioral therapy
and the like does work because our
thoughts can also work to change our
brain you know it's this interactive
system so you can either work sort of
from the bottom up or the top down
um but either way it's both you know
it's just two sides of the same coin
yeah so can you talk about some of the
particular conditions that you think
there's good for like good opportunities
to UM to make inroads on treating people
yeah I think any disorder whether
neurological or psychiatric there's
always some room for improvement or you
know people can change themselves they
can change their their brain some
disorders are a little bit more amenable
to treatment than others right and it
varies their individual differences so
for example personality disorders are a
little bit harder to treat a much harder
to treat than some other disorders
because they seem to be very fundamental
and like very much you know children who
are born with a certain temperament
tends that you can predict kind of how
their personality is going to be the
rest of their life and it's pretty sort
of hardwired in and much harder to
change then say treatment or a phobia
for example you know if you have let's
say if you're flying there are certain
like behavioral and cognitive techniques
we can use to help treat that and and
it's gonna be pretty amenable to
treatment in many cases whereas treating
say like a narcissistic personality
disorder is much harder to treat because
it's just sort of part of your DNA it's
part of the way you're wired but I do
see a lot of potential right now in
terms of novel treatments in the use of
psychedelics
it's like psychedelic medicine to treat
so for example MDMA or like ecstasy to
treat PTSD and other anxiety disorders
ketamine to treat depression psilocybin
or mushrooms to treat certain types of
anxiety and we're looking at other
disorders as well
so including depression so I think a lot
of these novel treatments are pretty
exciting but it hasn't been a lot of
movement in the world of psychiatry for
you know I would say half a century but
we're starting to make some you know
except for like minor tweaks and things
you know SSRI okay this is a little bit
more selective serotonin one this is
slightly more selective but you know
nothing really major breakthrough so I
think we're swirl right the precipice of
making those big breakthroughs now I get
you so that would be really interesting
to get your stance on psychedelics and
how or why they work because from a
subjective experience you take a
particularly strong psychedelic you have
a subjective experience of seeing
something being somewhere but what's
happening neurologically at the level of
the brain must be completely different I
don't know what's actually happening so
can you take us through what happens if
i take a therapeutic dose of MDMA or if
I take a therapeutic dose of psilocybin
so it's different for the different
drugs so each drug is different
mechanism and we're still in the very
early stages so there are different
theories about why the different drugs
work one let's say I'll take a
psilocybin which works on the serotonin
receptors in the brain but one thing
that it does as well as like LSD and
other psychedelics is it tends to in a
very general sense open you up in many
ways so parts of the brain that are
involved in your sense of self and your
ego you tend to kind of decrease in
activations so you tend to feel like one
with everything right you kind of get
this disillusion of your sense of your
ego and a lot of these pressure breeding
like the prefrontal cortex when they're
really highly active or involved in like
rumination and anxiety or like when
you're depressed and you have these
thoughts that you just can't get out of
your head these negative thoughts and
this kind of helps break that cycle it
also helps you kind of make there you
see a lot of novel activation across
these long range networks in the brain
where a lot of the time there's a lot of
local communication or is now it kind of
opens things up so you're thinking of a
completely different way but so there's
a lot of
what's happening at the hardware in the
brain but but I think a lot of the
therapeutic effects of this kind of
these kind of drugs is is the
psychological effect because you only
need to take it one or two times like
with a guided with a therapist for it to
have this long-lasting effect whereas
other drugs let's say an SSRI that you
take for depression no selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitor you have it
always has to be in your system like it
only works while it's in your system and
as soon as it wears off that's we have
to take it every day right so they're
saying okay it's clearly the effects of
the drug itself or is with the
psychedelics it seems to be the
psychological experience that's
profoundly like shifts your
consciousness or your perspective and
has these long-term long-term impact how
do you as a neuroscientist look at that
situation I have a particular experience
I've not drilled or greased a particular
thought groove a lot
I've not wrapped tons of myelin around
one particular way of being and yet this
particular experience has been so
profound or changing that it's caused
everything downstream to alter what's
what's that mean what happened okay so
like when you have when you're talking
about you know actual changes in the
physical structure of the brain talking
about things like long-term potentiation
or like when you're learning something
and you develop a new pathway in the
brain you know by like rehearsing it
over and over again right and that
doesn't seem to happen with this but
there is also something you know called
one trial learning so like often this
happens with something like a very
negative experience and it's an adaptive
it's adaptive because let's say you know
back in the caveman days you know you're
foraging through the forest you get
really violently ill by eating a
particular berry right so for survival
it makes sense to like really remember
that berry in that experience and never
go near it again so basically you know
you get sick from it one time and that's
all it takes for you to like avoid it
and you know and we know that from now
like if you ever get food poisoning from
something you know you won't touch that
food for a while and that's adaptive
right so you learn it and so with the
drugs it seems like it's a very profound
one-time experience right that might
shift the way that you think about
things and then over
time that shift in your thought process
will start to develop new pathways and
new ways of thinking right but it's such
a profound you know it has to be like
such a heightens level of experience
whether they're positive or negative
that it can really shift how you think
which then can go on to create these new
long-term pathways that's so fascinating
the evolutionary basis for it as well
and it makes total sense you've got this
very very intense experience like you
either want to have it happen again
you find this unbelievable kill or you
you come up with a new way of taking
down a particular prey or whatever it
might be or you know the negative side
you do something that you don't ever
ever ever want to do again that's so I
mean it works it's so we're kind of like
hacking into the sort of you know
cavemen brain in a sense and again it
can work I guess you like when people
have a traumatic experience right that
also can stick with that right something
very negative happens it's you know in a
soldier in war and they see like their
friend almost dies or does die you know
that can have such a profound effect
that it causes all these negative
psychological effects after so I think
with the psychedelics it's trying to
take that having a very something very
intense positive you know experience
that then sticks with you over time and
helps change your brain in a positive
way rather than a negative way stay with
like PTSD so what about MDMA
what's the do you have an understanding
of the reasoning for that so with MDMA
it's more about and with the psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy which it's called
it's a it's about so often there's a
sort of traumatic experience like what's
your PTSD and then our brain we put up
these kind of protective mechanisms
because if it kept coming to the surface
and we had to think about it all the
time it would be maladaptive and
interferes with our daily life so we
suppress it but yet it goes on to affect
our behavior right so you know we're
we're anxious or hyper vigilant or
having nightmares right and one way to
sort of resolve that is to gain
conscious access of that unconscious
memory that might be suppressed let's
say and reintegrate it into the brain in
a more neutral way so it's not
intimately can
with the negative emotion so you know
for instance I don't know let's say it's
a I mean somebody was like sexually
assaulted you know you could be able to
like think about that assault and really
think about in your mind but kind of
separate it from the terrible emotions
that it brings up so with the MTA it's a
way to allow people to remember these
traumatic experiences in a neutral way
in fact in a way where they're feeling
very calm and a bit pleasurable so that
it can kind of reassociate these these
memories with with more at least neutral
emotions so that they're not constantly
every time they're triggered it triggers
a negative emotion right so it's about
kind of restructuring abate and also
allowing you to access unconscious
processes that when you're in your sort
of normal defensive state you're not
even allowed that they don't even come
to the surface right so it's sort of a
way to access the unconscious and then
reintegrate the memories in a more
neutral way yeah I keep on seeing so
much about psilocybin MDMA and Tim
Ferriss is donating tons and tons of
money to MDMA therapy and psilocybin
therapy because that's how much he how
much sort of future and how much
efficacy he thinks is in these
treatments it's so it's so mad that's
something that's a party drug that's
seen as people as this kind of ravers
drug from Woodstock or Creamfields or
whatever it might be to now be something
that's potentially changing the lives of
soldiers with PTSD or people that are
addictive got addictions and
dependencies or people that have had
traumatic childhoods yeah yeah yeah
again it's not just you know it's with
doing it with somebody who's trained to
help you let's say gain access to these
memories
um I think just during the drug itself
without having that guided psychological
experience doesn't have the same impact
in conjunction you know with the therapy
yeah or else everyone that was walking
out of Creamfields or ultra festival in
Miami would just be complete there that
absolute no no inhibitions left
everything to be working fine right
everything great come
and everything come to a music festival
get a brain MOT come out and you're
working everything's working brilliant
oh he's great so um I want to kind of
really try and dig into what it means
that we have conscious experience what
it means that we can think of things and
that we can remember things and that
they appear in our consciousness can you
can you kind of try and take us through
how that is occurring within the brain
so what what it means to have to be
conscious or what so I am I'm able to
picture something now so I'm able to
picture an elephant on my desk in front
of me and in my mind I can think of an
elephant on the desk well III don't
understand how my brain is able to make
that elephant appear in my mind or when
I close my mind I can think of something
which is a past memory I don't
understand how it these particular
processes a bunch of synapses firing
actually creates a landscape or a sense
of a smell or any of this sort of stuff
I mean I want to be honest but that is
the big question is why is it that these
sort of neuro chemicals flushing around
and electrical impulses happening in
these neurons can create these
subjective experiences like the image of
an elephant we need you know that for
example when you so there's been a lot
of work on the individual system in the
brain right how we see something and for
example when you see say a sunset you
know we see a particular pattern of
activation in the visual cortex of your
brain there's parts of the visual cortex
that are involved in color perception
and movements and each like aspects of
let's say a visual scene you're seeing
we can divide it up into different sort
of segments within let's say the visual
cortex or the visual stream let's say
it's true stream of information and we
see and the reason I study for example
people with psychiatric or neurological
disorders is because it helps us get
gives us insight like when something's
broken into actually how it actually
works
like you know when your car is running
fine you know relatable and there's a
problem all right then you should I
figure out okay is it the car we read or
whatever I don't know a lot about cars
but is broken you can understand how it
works a little bit better
like with the visual system for example
some people get a brief lesion and they
can no longer at like see color right so
they can see movement and and and you
know but they just things are in black
and white or there's another part of the
visual cortex if you get damage like
movement is taken away so they say
everything in kind of like staccato so
like like film you know kind of like
cuts mm-hm
right and so that helps us understand
how it's all working so we understand a
bit about like when information comes
into the so you know you get your your
your retina stimulated then we know
opposed to like the the thalamus which
is kind of a relay station in the brain
which then sends the information the
visual cortex and then it's not
conscious yet then it has to come back
up through to the prefrontal cortex and
you need these kind of feedback loops
until it comes into conscious perception
so we're learning about like what is
happening to bringing one thing when
something when a certain stimuli becomes
conscious at the moment we're
consciously aware of it what needs to be
in place so we're looking at for the the
minimal what's sufficient you know
necessary amount of activation for any
conscious events to occur what's
interesting is that when you imagine say
a sunset you get the same areas of brain
activation in those visual cortices is
when you're actually seeing it and
there's only there's other sort of
circuits inter-korean that signal to us
whether that is coming in externally or
being generated internally so we
understand the difference between
imagining something or not but certain
people let's say with schizophrenia they
lose that distinction so they think for
example the voices which are really
coming internally you know you have that
little voice in your head but you know
it's you right but they lose the
distinction so they think somebody's
talking to me you know it's coming from
externally or you know hallucinations
it's really normally you know it's just
my imagination but when you lose that
distinction let's say you're on a
hallucinogenic drug or you have
schizophrenia you think it's really out
there right so our brain it's all
happening in our head really I mean you
know and and what we perceive in our
head doesn't necessarily correlate to
reality you know we're we're making
these approximations all the time some
of it you know is better correlated than
others
but it's all in our imagination really
yes some of it gets by stimuli coming in
but it's still a recreation of what you
know we think is happening I'm reminded
of the example was a railway worker who
accidentally had something shoot through
his brain and then I think there's
another example yeah there's another
example of a man who killed his family
and then went up on a bell tower
shooting everybody and it turned out
that that was because of a tumor that
was affecting some area of his brain
that encouraged aggressiveness so I
suppose that those are two examples in
your earlier example of someone who has
a blockage that stops them from being
able to see color stops them from being
able to see movement that you can pick
apart the individual elements of how we
consciously experience things right yes
yeah yeah and it can change her
personality I mean so you get like
Phineas Gage he had a metal tamping iron
going through his prefrontal cortex and
he went from being a mild-mannered man
to being impulsive and aggressive you
have the man who you know killed a bunch
of people when they found he had a tumor
there's another man who also he was
doing some sort of pedophilia like
behavior they were about to put him in
jail he started getting these headaches
and then they found this big tumor in
his prefrontal cortex and then they
removed the tumor and all the symptoms
went away you know he was allowed to
return back home but then about a year
later the symptoms came back and sure
enough the tumor had come back so you
know we're going from sort of
correlation to causation right it's
changes your brain affecting who you are
and how you behave and now we're doing
treatments like for intractable
psychiatric illness so basically we're
other first-line treatments haven't
worked something called deep brain
stimulation where we actually implant
electrodes in people's brains in some
cortical areas evolutionarily older
parts of the brain and can change the
behavior we can help treat their OCD or
their depression long so we're really
starting to go in and manipulate the
brain itself to change behavior it's
just okay yeah and we can control it
with a remote control you know how
Wow Wow yeah I think one of the one of
the questions that I'm trying to
articulate here is that I'm able to see
what I do with my body right raise my
arm lower my arm I also have that same
conscious control over the things that
are in my head but I don't have them
with I don't have control in quite the
same way as I have control over my body
if I don't want to raise my arm now it's
quite easy for me not to do that but if
I say don't think about an elephant
really hard for the person that's
listening not to think about an elephant
does that make sense the fact that we
seem to have much more control over our
the way that our body moves than what
our minds think everyone that's
listening will know what it's like to
have heard a song earlier in the day and
just be doing the bed on the night time
and it's just the chorus I like two
lines from the chorus just nailing you
as you're desperately trying to have
some peaceful sleep mm-hmm do we have an
understanding neurologically about why
that's happening why it's so much yeah
challenging for us to control our minds
and our thoughts right than it is to say
control a body part well I mean okay so
first of all the different circuits in
the brain no I I I'm actually writing a
book now about impulse control you know
how to control our impulses our urges
our behaviors right so somebody there
are people out there who for example
can't control body movements people with
ticks
right a tics disorder where they have
these uncontrollable urges to move let's
say you know a body part and they just
can't seem to suppress that so there are
times when we have an urge to do
something physically but we are able to
then suppress it the thing that brain is
always active it's always on right it's
always humming away in the background
and you know at certain points thoughts
pop up right and we can either kind of
suppress them or but we can't stop them
from just popping up and so the way the
motor system works is slightly different
right so it's not like randomly like the
arm will start to move or you know we
have more it's sort of called by
conscious volition you
over the that but our thoughts are
different and so we can't like I often
say to people with say OCD that's a
compulsive disorder they have these
obsessive thoughts that can't stop now
you might not be able to stop the
thoughts themselves but you can you can
control the behavior so usually you have
an obsession like I'm gonna catch like
right now there's the coronavirus right
that's really scary
somebody must be constantly thinking
about it and anxious about it and in
order to relieve the anxiety they wash
their hands but then they're washing
their hands you know 10 times a day so
part of the treatment is well you can
control the behavior you can't control
the thought from coming so when you have
the thought we have to not do the
behavior and over time the thought will
eventually start to subside because
basically what you want to do is have
[ __ ] weight to the anxiety so when you
wash your hands you're basically getting
rid of the anxiety and not and not and
so the cycle keeps happening but if you
force yourself to sit with the anxiety
not wash your hands eventually the
thoughts will start to subside so yeah
we have more control over a physical
behavior in most cases than we do our
thoughts but we can control how we
respond or react to our thoughts and we
can reframe our thoughts and you know
contextualize them and things it's very
hard to just stop them from naturally
coming up and that's a lot of what
meditation is it's like allowing the
thoughts to come up and just observe
them and kind of be separated from them
or a bit distance and not having to like
emotionally react to that yeah I've had
a number of discussions recently one
being with Aubrey Marcus about not
fixating or suppressing when something
arises so that equanimity right that
just allowance that it is and then it
goes and then it is and it goes right
and that's certainly something that I
know my friends who are significantly
more experienced meditators than me sort
of talked about enjoying on a day-to-day
basis counter-intuitively so the more
you try to suppress it the more it's
likely to come up so like with the
elephant if I'm like don't think about
it don't become an elephant so the idea
is to kind of in a way go into it be
like if you're afraid of some
thing like it's or are you getting
anxious like if you're about to have a
panic attack be like okay let's see how
anxious can I get you know sizzle yeah
like let's make it more because the more
you try to not be anxious the more
anxious you're gonna get the more you
try to not think about that the more
you'll think of it so it's like let's go
let's move into it you know be like okay
let's think about the best elephant you
could possibly think of and all sorts of
you know ways to think of it after a
while your skin so sick of the game
elephant you're knocking a lot of think
of it anymore so it's like kind of
attitude of how you have to stop
suppressing in order to get rid of
something do you think that that's
reflected when people have challenging
experiences in psychedelic trips so a
lot of the time people will say if you
see a big snake or something scary don't
run away from it run toward it is that a
symbolic version of what we're talking
about you
yeah pretty similar exactly because the
more you try to run away the worse
that's gonna get so you should just go
into it and then eventually it'll
dissipate yeah so hilariously you've got
a a symbolic representation in a
psychedelic state of something which is
much more common and usually travelled
by people in a normal day-to-day State
right you've got the thought that's
coming up and you're running away from
it and that's actually making it worse
and now that's manifest as a dragon or a
snake or a guy in a hooded jacket or
whatever it might be yeah I thought what
we do with kids like with OCD we can't
we kind of make a metaphor that will
call the OCD monster and you know like
that thought is just the OCD monster
coming and you know you can't be scared
of it you just have to like confront it
and so it's kind of similar I guess
therapy with children is like dealing
with adults on a psychedelic trip they
do say that actually there's this great
work by alison gopnik who's a child
psychologist at berkeley and talks about
the baby's brain because the prefrontal
cortex is a plate developed until like
you're 25 but that's normally what
filters all the sort of random stimuli
coming in because the brain is trying to
make sense of it but that being a baby
the the kind of conscious experience of
a baby is it's kind of like a
psychedelic trip it's very similar to
that everything is just like you know
cool and moving you know I had you know
kids and so I've seen it like they look
like
tripping so it could be a very similar
analogy yeah that's well I think being
around my business partners kids he's
got a three year old and a six month old
now and um I might not have said at
first glance psychedelics but I would
have definitely said alcohol like he's
just like a little drunk running around
now he's a fireman now he's bouncing off
stuff yeah just be easy actually to be
fair the last time that I went in he
just had a cookie like quite a iced
cookie and apparently that just sent him
through the roof that was that was the
MDMA hitting him those did like a child
MDMA that's right cookies are child
MDMA yeah that's interesting I see what
it is um so I want to get back to what
we were talking about just before where
we said that um you can be you can have
a thought arise which you didn't
consciously come up with so it's not as
if you thought of your fear about the
coronavirus it just appears in
consciousness if it's not something that
you've started yourself where does that
come from
ah that's yeah and often a question is
where two thoughts come from where do
they start and it's really very hard
there's to sort of find the initiation
of a thought because as I said the brain
is always in flux and always in movement
so one sort of idea or kind of metaphor
is that and we could and this is
basically taken from research which
looks at brain activation and the rest
but basically if you think of it like
you know the waves coming in on the
shore right and they're coming in and
like some are bigger some are less you
know and at some point like these kind
of brain waves reaches sort of threshold
just by the random fluctuations in
activation in the brain and when it
crosses a certain let's say height or a
threshold that's when it suddenly comes
into consciousness
so it's this this constant random
movement and activation always like
things fluttering around until they
accidently sum up which is something a
little bit greater that
reaches a threshold and then we become
aware of it so there's no sort of one
place in the brain where it happens but
you can kind of think of it a bit like
you know this oscillatory firing of
neurons and at some point they sync up
in such a way that it brings them up
into conscious awareness and so then we
have this idea of like oh you know we
have control over the thoughts but
really we're just kind of like pushing
the system a little bit in one way or
the other it's like a system that's
already active and then we have some
control about where it goes but often
it's just doing much of it on its own
you know sometimes we kind of take steer
it or you know control of it a little
bit but then it goes off on its own
again that was precisely my next
question how much control over our
thoughts do we have yeah it's a hard all
the big questions today Heather I'm
really sorry I know you know I love two
minds on this because a lot of the
research and the things that I'm
interested in are like related to free
will right and you know how much control
we really have according to neuroscience
you know basically the brain decides
first and we become consciously aware of
that after the fact right we can see a
buildup of brain activation this goes
all the way back to classic experiments
by Benjamin a little bit in the 1980s
where you know he said like press this
button whenever you get the urge and
then measured brain activation and then
you could see a buildup of brain
activation about 350 milliseconds before
the person was even consciously aware of
their intention to move right and so and
now with more modern neuroscience we can
see it up to ten seconds before a person
is even consciously aware like for
example whether they're going to go left
or right well you know they're gonna
make a decision on their own so I often
say the brain we don't have free will
but maybe our unconscious does you know
the brain is deciding but you are your
brain and we're just the last to know
about it so in that sense I don't think
we have a huge amount of control however
we have evolved the capacity to have
self-control so this prefrontal cortex
like the brake system in the brain so we
have this like urge to do something
and then maybe we have some forethought
like maybe that's not the best thing you
know to do right now you know like I
don't know I want to like in the street
like maybe not a good idea right so then
that's not ever have that urge but you
know other people although you're among
friends here it's fine private just this
will go beyond our conversation um but
then you know you you have this okay
maybe I shouldn't do that and you'll
suppress it but some people whether they
have a brain lesion and the prefrontal
cortex are under activation or other
kinds of psychiatric illness where they
can't control that so so I do think that
we have evolved the capacity to have
self control even if we don't have like
free will in the classic kind of
philosophical sense in that like if
everything was happening exactly the
same way in your brain you could have
done otherwise which would mean there's
sort of a ghost in the machine
controlling things no I think there was
Sheen is controlling things but the
machine has evolved the capacity to have
a bit of control over itself so we do
have some control mm-hmm limits and like
also for people in therapy you know
let's say you you're a really anxious
kind of personality type with therapy I
can get you to be a little bit less
anxious but you're never gonna be the
most relaxed person in the room it's
just you know so there's movement within
certain biological constraints that's so
interesting I've been Luke who is a
friend that will be listening I send him
Sam Harris talking about free will on
Joe Rogan I sent him this probably about
a year ago from now and it sent him into
a two-week spiral of depression oh
because he thought that life was
essentially meaningless and I've never
felt so bad I was thinking about it last
night I messaged him today saying hey
man how are you doing that you in work
tonight turns out he is and I was
thinking about last night now I sent
someone one video it's 40 minutes Sam
Harris really shoves the red pill down
everyone's throat about his view on free
will okay a spiral them into two weeks
of depression you've got a powerful tool
a or what tool when you're dealing with
people's thoughts and emotions
I mean it's like planting the seed and
you know um but you know the studies
show that when you tell people they
don't have free will like when you tell
them about these neuroscience studies
and then you test them after they're
more likely that behaved unethically
it's a cheat on an exam so the illusion
of free will is actually very adaptive
we've evolved to have this very strong
sense of control over our own agency for
reason because it helps us interact with
social environments right if we know
that we have control if we think we have
control over actions and we are
responsible for actions and then we're
going to behave and we are socially
appropriate if you're you know if you
think well it doesn't matter anyway my
brain is deciding you know I could just
like kill this person and say my brain
made me do it
right so the strong illusion of free
will it evolved for it has a purpose and
when you break it you know it can it can
affect people although listen this
philosopher once said this to me I think
it was John Searle who's this well-known
philosopher like even if you if I tell
you it or not free will you know is it
really gonna change any of your behavior
it's not because fundamentally the
illusion is still existing right you
know if I say like okay when you see
something you're not really seeing it's
just like these neurons firing in the
original cortex or whatever you're still
getting the perception of seeing the
thing right so it doesn't change so the
illusion is still there even if I tell
you about it you get him momentarily
like you know there's a crack in your
illusion right you'd like break but what
is it the third wall the forward the
forward fourth wall if any right back
you know to where you were before so it
doesn't last very long
I hope so I've never heard that before
I've never heard that the subjective
experience of having free will is
Fitness enhancing and it totally makes
sense
oh you've just completely blown my mind
with that great that was one of my goals
for this
it's your Wow that's okay well I'm not
totally right as one I mean you know
perfect example exact ace in point like
I told my friend go and have a look into
this freewill thing he did and then he
went down the rabbit hole of that every
freewill video on YouTube that he could
find went through the full works went
through
then has just come out as this complete
is it determinism is that the particular
yeah viewpoint so now he's just
completely subscribes to that but you
were right he was like he didn't want to
go at the gym he's at what's the point
in me going to the gym I'm not going to
go at the gym if I don't go to the gym
see no and it all makes sense
wow that's really reading yeah there's
actually a documentary film coming out
on free well and actually my husband
doesn't he's a rapper and he raps about
science and he's doing a rap on it about
free will and the illusion of free will
and the kind of argues a way around it
like there's like something called
compatible determinism and I won't even
try to describe it it's all
philosophical but it's sort of a way to
kind of get us out of it a little bit
like even though everything's sort of
determined from the Big Bang on like
there is some you know there's some
indeterminacy there it's not nothing to
do with the with that that also let me
just take this away for now a lot of
people want to talk about the what is it
called molecular Costa States quantum
states exactly conceive it and because
there's indeterminacy at the quantum
level whatever it like none of that
scales up to like whether a neuron fires
or not yes it cell eject era hugs
professor Sean Carolyn recently yeah
yeah so I had him on and he said exactly
the same as that that you can talk about
what's happening at the quantum level
and it in theory is how everything acts
but it's not at all how our conscious
experience of the world exists and this
the quantum uncertainty principle that
we've got just it's not enough to it
doesn't create the special stuff to
allow to allow things to change in that
way which is what I think you're getting
at yeah it doesn't scale up for instance
because we're living at the macro level
of physics right classical physics not
quantum physics and so if we were going
if we were I said basically it's an
emergent property so you have these
things that are happening at the quantum
level but they don't scale so if we were
living by the rules of quantum physics
we could disappear at any moment like
switch states right like all of a sudden
I'm here and they're not here
right so that doesn't happen so just
because there's these quantum effects
happening at that level doesn't scale up
to the emergent properties of like
what's happening at the classical
physics level and like whether neuron
fires are not so it's just not a way and
I like some people want to try to argue
free well into that somehow but it just
doesn't work I think yeah to the people
that are listening I think they're
talking about what one earth you talking
about I've got free well I can choose
whether I put my right hand to the table
on my left onto the table I have free
will all the time I can choose to think
of an elephant I can choose to think of
the color red or a memory or a smell or
whatever it might be I do I want to
suggest right I'm gonna link the
particular episode the video of Sam
Harris talking to Joe Rogan about free
well I'm gonna link it in the show notes
but I'm warning you that if you decide
to watch it I'm not responsible for you
going into a two-week depression spiral
and also Luke I'm really sorry for
telling thousands of people about the
fact that I made you sad for a couple of
weeks month where you can do you are you
sure you want to open this link are you
really sure that you want to open this
link taking the red pill on nuts yeah
that's great like warning yeah you might
be totally crushed but the good news is
it all it won't last long like you'll go
right back it's such a strong illusion
that you can't you can't get around it
like that's that's what John's most
likes music even if you know free will
is an illusion is it really gonna change
how you behave and fundamentally it's
not so the knowledge comes in and then
it goes right back out again you know
you have like a moment of like wow
that's crazy but then you know what
really doesn't feel that way yeah right
you just gonna get you gonna get around
I've got stuff to do I can't be thinking
about the fact that I don't choose
whether or not I do this stuff I just
need to go do it exactly it's like the
examples like if you're at a restaurant
and like you want to order you sit there
like I don't there's no free well like I
can't you know like ultimately at some
point the brain just does what it does
and it decides it's also like telling
people like their sense of self like
self is an illusion like it's a
construct of the brain there is no self
like it's basically like your brain when
you were 3
different than what your brain is now
but you still have this continuity like
oh that was me right that person at
whatever five was me but really your
sense of self is a construct it's
another perception in the brain that
creates created by your memories and
things like people who lose their
memories lose their sense of self they
don't even know who they are anymore
right and there's all different sorts of
disorders where people have you know
changes in their sense of self so it's
just another process of the brain that's
also an illusion but again it's so
strong that we can't get away from it
there are moments like on psychedelics
where you lose your sense of self and
you feel this connectedness and it's a
very powerful very positive emotion
because a lot of our sense of self has
to do with self consciousness and
worrying what other people are thinking
and all of that whereas if you can let
go of that it can be very therapeutic
but what does what does a prolonged
sense of self look like in the brain is
that particular neurons wired together
is that kind of why actually manifests
as it's a particular route of of neurons
that tend to wire together and fight
together no I wouldn't say that we found
in the brain like a particular you know
pathway or you know like that's where
the self is instantiated there are a
couple of key areas in the brain where
we think our sense of self and one has
to do with our body awareness like our
sense because it's our sense of self and
also being a part of this body right and
those are interrelated so there's
certain like key sort of hotspots in the
brain where that help us form our sense
of self there's no kind of one place or
one pathway it's a lot of interconnected
pathways that give us our sense of of
self this a very is a very famous
British comedy show and in it one of the
guys is talking about the fact he's had
this broom for 20 years I've had this
broom for 20 years and I said 20 years I
can't believe it like how have you
managed to keep it so long he says yeah
yeah well it's had 14 new handles and 13
new heads but I've had this broom for
the last 20 years and that always makes
me think about the way that our bodies
refresh right I think is it's seven
years within the space of seven years
every cell in our body is going to have
changed so it will have been it'll have
died and been replaced and then come
back and yet we are the
but unlike the unlike the broom for
which that was definitely not the case
we are the same person
right Heather you are the viewer the
person that is here to tell us whether
or not I'm the same person I was seven
years ago yeah there are parts of you
that are there are parts of you that is
this them is the same person but much of
you is different and so you know in
terms of neuroplasticity in terms of the
way your brain is changing there are
certain things that stay fundamental and
stable but who you are is is really
developing and evolving throughout your
entire life
until your very last day like I've said
as I said this in my TED talk as well
like your work in progress until your
very last breath you're always changing
you're always evolving you're always
kind of redefining yourself and trying
to figure out your identity you know
like psychologists or what all these
different stages of development of your
identity but there's never really a
point where it's like okay that's it
like we're done you know it's okay it's
like evolution you know we're all
evolving as a species and we're still
evolving right we haven't just stopped
evolving like maybe in you know a
thousand years we're gonna be a slightly
different species or 2,000 or 10,000
however slow it's going but we're still
evolving and that's just like within our
own individual lives we're still
changing you know if we meet again on
this podcast in 20 years which I'm sure
you're still be doing in 20 years from
now we will you know you'll be a bit of
a different kind of a person you'll have
had different experiences your brain
will have changed so again you'll have a
perception of continuity but but you but
how much are you really the same I mean
it's an open-ended question really of
genius you know especially a lot of
people that go through big life changes
and you think well the person I am now
of us is a person that was seven years
ago is so different that the only thing
we both have in common is that we've
both been in exactly the same spatial
location between then and now and we
have memories from before that point and
that's it that's all that you share with
this person that used to be you this
it's a collection of memories you know
it's these memories it's memory storage
I mean you should have seen me as a teen
I mean I have no idea who that person
was but you know I think it's still me
because that's a memory set that I've
carried with me you know but actually
have just been someone else right it
could have been someone else but it
wasn't it was you right
and it's really just because it's okay
this this physical package of you know
cells that are collection of things that
as you said have changed over that time
period anyway they're not even the same
cells so it's just it's just basically
an instantiation of information that's
been carried over in this kind of in our
hippocampus which is a memory section of
the brain that like alright I don't know
if it's a CPU I'm very bad at computer
analogy I have no idea the RAM I don't
know anyway I get you you know it makes
it makes sense though is this I'm going
to guess that this will be Fitness
enhancing as well to have this continual
sense of self that allows you to kind of
compound wisdom and learning over time I
remember I once did something that maybe
wasn't so traumatic that it goes into
the total change your perspective thing
but I once put my hand in the fire and
the fire burned me I don't wanna do that
again etc etc is that right absolutely
yeah yeah it's all I think part I mean
some theories even about consciousness
say it involved because we evolved
memory working memory so basically you
know keeping things online there's a
party brain called the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex which is kind of like
the working online memory like when you
are like remembering a phone number and
you're setting it over and over again so
I keep it in that space and that what we
had said sort of developed these
recursive loops to keep things on line
and it was adaptive that is sort of what
helped bring us into sort of these
conscious states as well because you had
a lot of this kind of recurring like
information and it's one theory of how
consciousness develops but to be able to
remember and not do the same sort of bad
behavior or you know learn where the
tiger is hiding and so you know not to
go there or worry about the good kill
that's all adaptive and then part of it
is it could just be up as a consequence
we started picking up memories about
ourselves right so not just about what's
happening in the environment but maybe
internal states that we've had
previously you know oh I remember you
you know how that person made me feel
maybe I don't want to interact with that
person anymore
you know but I think it's it's memory is
certainly an adaptation that helped us
to survive and then came theory of mind
try it being able to predict how you
might behave or how well your thinking
would give me an advantage right and so
it's just another you know a gift
evolution has given us
I had a William von Hippel on do you
know who William is no I don't know no
von Hippel so I love that name though oh
yes yeah he's an absolute boss he's such
a boss so his book talks about
Australopithecus and the move to from
apes in trees to upright animals on
planes and he talks about the throwing
the development of the throwing arm and
he talks about the theory of mind and he
talked about the fact that he there's
two two examples that he gives the first
one it's the first time that his son
lied about something and his wife was
really upset their son at leiden was
like no like Joshua you're not supposed
to lie and see secretly bill was like
kind of guests behind the scenes because
his son at Xian developed theory one for
the first time but the other thing they
talked about is this predicted
requirement for tools in the future so
there's good examples that our ancestors
didn't have this theory of mine because
they weren't able to predict required
needs let's say that they made a tool
use the tool for a particular purpose
then they would throw it down but as we
began to evolve and develop these tools
start to cluster together as opposed to
just being strewn around and what that
suggested was you made a tool you used
it and then you thought ah in the future
I'm going to need this tool I better
take it with me and I thought I thought
that that was so interesting to have
that happening the other you know what's
also interesting it's basically it's
because can you still hear me one of my
things died but you're gonna come we
humans are have developed we have the
largest prefrontal cortex compared to
the rest of the brain than any other
animal and
gives us our ability to have foresight
to think into the future and so we can
think further into the future than any
other animal which gives us a lot of
advantages but also disadvantages
because we're the one species that can
experience anxiety which is different
than fear
so fear is like you know in the
immediate situation
I'm your fraid right fight-or-flight
anxiety is the anticipation of a future
threat or fear or great and so that that
rumination that anxiety that the ability
to think ahead to think about our own
demise right to contemplate our own
death you know other animals are not
really sitting there doing that they're
living in the moment any other surviving
and but we get this unique ability to
have anxiety about the future but also
you know make these predictions like hey
maybe I'll need that tool in the future
maybe you know I mean other animals they
might do it instinctively I mean a bird
who builds a nest I mean they are
planning for the future right a squirrel
has stockpiles you know nuts is thinking
about the future but you know I don't
know how abstract that is you know I
just don't know if that's an adaptive
behavior that they kind of do
instinctively or are they really
thinking about like man you know it
might be a cold winter I better yeah
it's how conscious yeah how conscious is
or how much is it just North Pole versus
South Pole and those two things clicking
together I think yeah you know one of
the things that I often think about with
relation to my own brain is I've got
this memory from ages ago when I was
around an old girlfriend and I remember
looking at her dog and saying I wish I
wish that I was Daisy it would be so
much easier and simpler if I was Daisy I
was thinking that's actually really
profound to say that it's actually
really interesting to say well I would
lose so much of the depth of the anxiety
of the depression of the rumination of
the all this sort of stuff but I would
also lose the ability to be able to
think abstractly to be able to
contemplate the fact that I am here
thinking these thoughts and I thought I
mean she didn't realize it at the time
and I've never told her but yeah
I look at you know like babies really
young kids and they're just fully in the
moment right their prefrontal cortex is
a fully developed I mean they're kind of
like a cow just talking about this last
night with a friendly they can play
peek-a-boo like all night long I mean
it's ending and never bored it's always
like a surprise you know so or like a
cat you know chasing a light like it's
just constantly novel and so that's kind
of fun right
dogs don't feel guilt you know these
kinds of or shame I mean they might act
a little bit like we might end up
amorphize and think they are but these
very more complex emotions and so you
know I often wish sometimes I was just
like just as a human like less you know
I'm always thinking these big questions
whatever like can I just stop and just
you know chill out and I don't know
watch the Kardashians or something and
just be okay with that but I can't seem
to yeah so I think you know there's
pluses and minuses right you can live at
the moment I think that's what
meditation does is it kind of helps you
to just be purely in the moment and try
to release all the rumination and the
anxiety and the thoughts about the
future of the past and just be present
and be kind of like a dog is really
where you want to go with that to me
that sounds like a wonderful way for me
to live the rest of my life if I could
just be as simple as a dog that would be
beautiful but I also I also appreciate
what you mean someone asks I went to go
see Jordan Peterson lecture in
Manchester last year not two years ago
sorry and um someone asked a question
which was essentially the depth of my
consciousness causes me to suffer that
was broadly what the question was
interpreted as and it was the same as
use is ignorant bliss like can I can i
scale back the depth of my consciousness
and think about thinking less and think
about things less and Jordan gave it a
very typically sort of symbolic answer
but what he said was once you've opened
that Pandora's box is no real closing it
once you've realized the depth that your
mind can go to there's nothing that you
can do to stop it he says the only
choice really is to go deeper not to go
back because there is no retreat so he
says take more of the thing that poisons
you until you turn it into a tonic and
girdle the world around it that means
real grand and metaphysics think the way
that classic John
but I actually really like that I
thought you know when we're talking
about the crisis of overthinking the
crisis of worry and concern and anxiety
and what did you say right at the
beginning when we were talking about
something you have a fear over it's like
I have my worry about this particular
thing it's that right ok I'm gonna lean
into it I'm going to completely immerse
myself in whatever this thing is and
break it apart into its component pieces
what are the actual fundamental parts
that this is constructed of and that's
what I'm going to do I think there's no
there's something there I feel like
there's something there yeah no I like
that leaned into and the other every
night I'll say just about that is that
you know if I don't know you beliefs or
whatever but this is you know that one
chance we get of like being conscious
like sandwiched between two eternities
of nothingness right like let's try to
get as much as we can get out of this
experience all right you know we have
this limited this little piece of matter
this brain that limits our ability to uh
sort of understand the world around us
like we're seeing it all through this
walk an organ but whatever it allows us
to see or think or contemplate like like
I want to experience as much of it as I
can you know with the good and the bad
right the further the greater depth of
experience I can have I mean if this is
my one and only chance to just be
conscious and experience things then I
want like the fullest gamut of it all so
I choose you know not an ignorance and
with whatever that may come with because
that's the fullness of life that's
really beautiful well wonderful way to
finish Heather thank you so much yeah um
once you book going to be done oh that's
a good question um so I'm writing it now
and it's due next year so I'm hoping
optimistically it's going to be the end
of next year the working title is the
fine art of losing control that's cool I
like it yeah it's about sort of impulse
control when to rein in in how to rein
it in is there any control really and
then when to let it go and how letting
go in a controlled way can
counter-intuitively
allow you to gain more control that's
cool I look forward to it thank you yeah
people want to hustle you online people
want to find you where should they go
Heather Berlin calm
and I'm on Twitter and Instagram at
Heather underscore Berlin lovely links
will be in the show notes below as
always if you've enjoyed it like share
subscribe you know what to do any
questions comments or feedback just
leave them in the comments on YouTube
and I'll I'll send them over to Heather
and she can come and she can come and
that pop by and say hi or whatever it
might be but Heather it's been awesome
thank you so much thank you so much
[Music]
you